comme en espagne amigos et stand chez
mais pas venir cette phrase si seulement
je devais sortir mon oral de bach celle
là comment allez-vous moi tout va
extrêmement bien mais j'aimerais que ça
aille encore mieux alors aujourd'hui on
va faire un truc très positif
un sobre et dit très positif est ce que
c'est les séquelles du fait que je
culpabilise encore un peu d'avoir sorti
deux vidéos badens d'affilée bienvenue
dans le sobre et dit soleil dit alors se
seraient dit il est beaucoup moins
connue que tout ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
présent mais pourtant il en est que
meilleure en gros c'est que des gif
gypse
le débat est ce qu'on dit gif ou est ce
qu'on dit gif la moitié de mes amis
disent l'un l'autre moitié l'autre ce
qu'on peut fixer la prononciation exacte
vous plaît merci
moi je dis j -ph ok bref c'est que des
juifs dans lesquelles il ya des humains
qui font des trucs hyper smooth qui se
rattrape d'une chute d'une manière hyper
clean qui fait un truc hyper fluide fins
et c'est fluide
d'ailleurs cette vidéo s'appellera ici
c'est fluide très mauvaise idée en
exemple la fluidité avec laquelle ce
prof de danse va faire sa demande en
mariage sa copine
[Musique]
aulas
au sa réaction je peux pleurer meilleur
couple de la décennie on n'a rien pu
faire
je rêvais il y avait un mec qui savait
faire ça quand j'étais à l'école
primaire je rêvais de savoir faire ça
bon il me fait vraiment bien pour le
coup n'essayez pas je viens de ces jeux
est responsable de 304 fracture du bras
qui dirige à l'hôpital alors que les
hôpitaux sont déjà surchargés n'essayez
jamais prévoir que quelqu'un arrête les
chiens qui font du skate [ __ ] ça que
vous pouvez vraiment apprendre à votre
chien faire du skate quand il est encore
petit c'est un truc de ouf
regardez la elle prend des escaliers
gréements
[Musique]
n'as tu regarde cette vidéo
voilà c'est ce genre de truc qu'on
aimerait que tu fasses toustou statut
préfère faire ça s'apparente la balle au
prisonnier
je suis en vie de balle au prisonnier là
tout d'un coup je pensais pas dire cette
phrase pour être honnête et année il
esquive feinte et lobby vert se trouve
pas que c'est sous côté la balle au
prisonnier qui adore un potentiel énorme
avec ce sport il ya un potentiel dingue
c'est que de la femme de l'agilité de
l'anticipation du nom écoutez moi bien
même si la balle au prisonnier se
retrouve au plus bas et qu'elle n'est
plus pratiquée dans les lycées dans les
colonies de vacances il y aura un
supporters dans les gradins ce sera moi
je serai toujours là d'accord à soutenir
la bresse-hohneck touchés que sont fans
de foot et de basket vous méprisez je le
vois lunch times delivery oula oula oula
ses films et attend quoi
il vient de faire tomber en big mac et
il l'a rattrapée en trois jongleurs
cristiano ronaldo sion 10 bravo
c'est tellement demos de dessins animés
les gars quand vous tentez un bout que
des persos fonds dans des dessins animés
que ça passe c'est vraiment stylé
derrière ce crédit sur ça il s'appelle
cartoon movement
il est incroyable et tout petits au
sénat je vous donne voix la même petite
souris dit perso qui sont minuscules
regardez par exemple typique d'un dessin
animé il ouvre la porte
il prend le sac d'un livreur et opinions
de la porte c'est vraiment les chiens
dans les dessins animés qui ferme la
porte comme ça ça me tue
qu'est ce qui va se passer on est
toujours sûr car tous nous mène non mais
les gars c'est hyper temps mais c'est
pas car tout le monde est là c'est des
dates grosses mauvaises ne fait jamais
ça faut jamais rigoler que c'est tout le
gonflable de merde là où quand tu sautes
sa éjecté l'autre on s'est tous fait
avoir avec quatre pattes en vacances
tous tous tout bon on est retour sur
l'egypte seront stockés d'euros
il va il va sur avoir la classique au
thème est arrivé au bsr ça s'était très
chiant what he said a remis des diplômes
il tombe
oh non non légal excusez moi mais c'est
pas ça du tout il a fait des ponts des
amis te rattraper en faisant des pompes
ce n'est pas ce style et c'est mettre
l'accent encore plus sur ta chute je
trouve moi je sui team on se relève
rapidement on fait comme si de rien
n'était pas pour moi il s'est mis en
péril on prend très au sérieux les
chutes et si vous avez vu c'est très
sérieux d'un coup roller blade england
steps fois on dirait que c'est dire est
que les marches n'existe pas c'est
incroyable olalala attendait un coup en
gagnant là le petit freinage de beau
gosse le petit poussant à l'herbe et
heures sur 10 quoi beating de roche ou
là haut mais il est sain et complète
c'est un mambo je comprends pas qu'ils
ce qu'il ait réussi à rentrer en fait
ils devaient être en train de sprinter à
côté je pense ils étaient à l'arrêt
c'est impossible de différencier sur 10
lui a arraché les mois il faut que
j'arrête
il attrape le bateau
[Musique]
quoi mais je veux faire ça salaire mais
c'est extraordinaire mais fait du ski
nautique sans skis mais qui est cet
homme
il est beaucoup trop à l'aise j'ai envie
qu'il lui arrive une chute vous rendez
compte
en général un foutu ski nautique
pourtant eu la géniale et de la jalousie
chez moi et de l' envie c'est vous dire
sa puissance quoi incroyable ce gars
extraordinaire salut c'est quoi un
oiseau qui slate
qu'elle craque il repart si calmement il
sait très bien ce qu'il a fait oiseaux
si on dise franchement incroyable il
impressionne assaf et le saf et le cake
ça monte sa musculature la voyez là on
est patient des pompes là on est sur un
bon équilibre regardez moi comme ses
jambes sont droites eu les suzerains
tous at on continue de plaire à sa
copine et ne pas marquer son esprit d'un
moment de faiblesse mâle alpha sur 10
[Musique]
ouah elle a rattrapé la carte qui adhère
la main et l'autre croyable elle est
blasé regarder on l'a déjà fait je vois
des magiciens toutes les semaines au
minium avoir un enfant sur 10 as et le
lancer de bouquet au mariage vous savez
en mariage la mariée l'an son bouquet
est celle qui le rattrape se veut dire
que ce sera la prochaine marié
[Musique]
oh
oh la la il n'a pas perdu de temps le
fils ou la ville a perdu 0 secondes
vous ne serez jamais aussi cool un chien
qui fait du pin spinning
c'est fou c'est fou puisque si le bâton
était tombé dans l'eau ce riddim et quel
idiot ce chien rats et les sympathiques
le dos mais là c'est juste le boss en
fait c'est juste le boss là incroyable
un sauvetage top tiers
mes frères on sait déjà où des ressorts
dans cette excuse moi même c'est dingue
cette capacité à se rattraper de manière
aussi cool merde au dessus de l'eau ouf
hélas hélas il arrive à sortir ou pas ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle se rattraper
bravo bonus pour le paysage incroyable
10 sur 10 bravo aux incroyables mais
[ __ ] alors je vous le débat quand même
parce que mes vidéos doivent rester
chiante est-ce que selon vous ces genres
de la chance ou du self control de
dingue parce que là il a quand même
régis super vite après avoir compris
qu'il avait agrippé le truc il a tout de
suite fait un mouvement balancier
étouffant attention donc chance ou ce
qu'ils au mix des deux peut-être nuance
mix des deux voilà en tout cas c'est un
moment chaud j'ai arrêté le skate
après avoir tenté d'apprendre le kick
flip et de mépris le skate pas comme lui
pas comme lui du tout ça m'est arrivé de
trois fois c'est chaouchi et bugs life
non pas la blague du gâteau non pour les
gars il faut clairement un chaque année
où il avait prévu une assiette contre
santos excusez moi mais c'est vraiment
un move de gars qui comme amar qui a
déjà trop subi cette blague un futur
briseurs de coeurs
du coup il a fait un bate n'est que
j'aurais jamais pensé qu'elle craque
il veut et le coeur de la fille et la
balle du joueur n'y a pas de concession
dans la vie de cet enfant c'est les deux
voilà tout ce qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
noir
et nous on est là en regardant ce bridge
excusez moi j'ai envie d'être très
cynique aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[ __ ] from pire anniversaire de sa vie
à ma meilleure amie vendeville
incroyable lui il était là juste pour
sauver le gâteau en cas de problème
certes poussé votre nom se termine
[Musique]
les gars c'est vraiment moi quand j
essaie de calmer des gens qui sont dans
un débat qui monte un peu trop haut dans
les tours
j'ai la même efficacité que lui c'est
terrible quand le bouton ignorer
l'annoncent à parler qu'est ce que c'est
que cette connerie a été cliqué sur le
bouton on va être riche ne sait jamais
mais je suis je suis dit [ __ ] mais le
pôle image qui avait on le voyait sortir
elles ont dégagé bas je comprends le
délire du lucky luke tire plus vite que
son ombre
moi j'ai toujours cru que c'était un
fantasme non non ça existe vraiment pas
une vanne en fait tu lèves toi ce n'est
jamais arrivé
mais la chute est d'une violence
il va si bien et là même le smile je
suspecte au fond d'être mort et d'être
devenu un esprit là une demi seconde
c'est pas lui les gars pas possible on
en la blague du gâteau encore comment
elle s'en est sorti mais là haut a dit
tu vois je vais pas me lasser bla bla du
gâteau là c'est un meurtre les gars
calmez vous qu on fait cette blague dans
le groupe ça va aussi
je remette paye mais je crois qu'elle a
mis la petite assiette sur son visage et
voilà les gars je ne connaissais pas
cette technique sachez que maintenant
dès que je soufflerai des bougies
j'aurai une assiette comme ça après du
torse ou cas où
messieurs dames c'est la fin de ce bris
dit j'espère qu'il vous a bien diverti
c'est bien de savoir se rattraper quand
on tombe mais le mieux c'est de ne pas
tomber
voilà ça c'est pour la petite morale de
fin nul je me suis bien amusé
aujourd'hui l'assurance l'énergie
positive
or il est vraiment pas mal il est pas
méga alimenter je vais être honnête
c'est un petit seule ride et aux niches
mais il fait plaisir allez y les leurs y
aller et de 0,4
[Musique]